okay let's go next to where do we want
to go let's go to the 708 area code
who's calling today from 7 0 8 hi hey
David I'm Alex and I'm calling from
Oakland Illinois hey what's going on
Alex hey so we were all really pleased
last year us as progressives when the
Democrats decided to take
super-delegates off of the first ballot
right Mike my question is um if someone
likes a Bernie Sanders or another
progressive fails to get the deeper set
of Delegates by the time the primary is
over can't they just like pega
corporatists with super-delegates when
the time of the convention comes you
know I think that your analysis is
correct that that could happen but I you
know I could either be naive or stupid
or correct or cynical or whatever I
think that Bernie's biggest liabilities
this time around are not related to the
DNC organizing against him I think that
the field is so broad at this point in
time that it would be number one just
more practically difficult to target an
anti Bernie strategy particularly since
so many other candidates have adopted
some of the positions that in 2016 were
unique to Bernie and I some part of me
thinks that if Bernie has a plurality of
those like if Bernie has imagined that
Bernie with 42% of the delegates going
into the convention has a plurality he
doesn't have 50% but nobody has more
than 42% I think if at that point the
DNC uses super-delegates to install some
corporate it's corporatist centrist
who's who's got eight or twelve percent
of the delegates so far I just don't
think that they can get away with it I
don't I don't think they're going to try
and I'm people might disagree with me I
just don't think it's gonna work this
time around there would be such outrage
yeah my worry is that the race will be
so close that the Democrats will make
some excuse like oh maybe Bernie Sanders
is controlled by a republican-controlled
state in Vermont which then the appoint
a Republican senator until a special
election comes on or maybe that he's
associated
and likely months not Vermont's not a
Republicans I know you're saying
hypothetically but that particular one
wouldn't really work because Vermont's a
very blue state isn't it controlled by a
Republican governor currently though
yeah well okay so but the legislature is
still quite left from the last time I
looked at it okay so they would have to
go through the legislature in order to
appoint a Republican senator I don't
know that they would but it's hard for
me to imagine that that is going to be
the way it shakes out you know I mean
maybe you're bringing up a good point I
mean maybe that's something to look at I
still think it'd be a bad reason if
Bernie has a plurality of the votes not
to sort of allow him to be the nominee
the the scenario you bring up is
different which is I guess you're saying
if Bernie has 38% and some corporates
his Democrat has 37% and then everybody
else is way below and the super
delegates at the convention on the
second round of voting push the other
person oh yeah I mean listen I hope it
doesn't happen I don't know what to say
about that but I hope that that does not
happen it's depressing to think about
quite frankly all right well thank you
for answering my question I really
appreciated okay no problem appreciate
the call